mais d'abord Lucas la nouvelle brigade
de sécurité dans les transports en
commun à tour Aurélien sa mise en place
avait été annoncé par le ministre de
l'Intérieur en 2022 elle est arrivée ce
matin à tour la toute nouvelle brigade
de sécurisation des transports en commun
contte une dizaine de policiers ils
seront chargés de lutter contre la
délinquence liée au transport outrage et
violence sexiste et sexuelle ou toute
atteinte aux personnes ou aux bien l
Turquie a suivi leur toute première
patrouille à
tour 11h40 la nouvelle unité prend ses
carart et pas n'importe lesquel c'est
dans le tramou ou encore dans le bus que
vous pourrez les croiser par groupe de 5
les agents veillent à la tranquillité
des passagers alors actuellement on fait
de la sécurisation dans les transports
en commun on est en tenue tenue de
service pour que re visible de la
population l'intérêt de venir dans les
transports en commun c'est pour assurer
une présence dans dans le cadre de la
police de proximité également doncavoir
toujours un contact permanent avec les
usagers en tenue ou bien en civil
l'unité vise à dissuader et lutter par
exemple emple contre les outrages la
délinquence ou les violences faites aux
femmes dans les transports ils
interviennent sur toute la ville de tour
du nord au sud 7 jours sur 7 un champ
d'action large permis par un partenariat
avec Keolis fil bleu et aussi la SNCF ce
matin la brigade s'arrête à la gare pour
prêter main forte à l'équipe de sûreté
ferroviaire est surtout en surveillance
gare avec des opérations conjointes avec
la SUGE qui surveill les TGV de temps en
temps les voyageurs les contrôles donc
on les assiste dans ces missions là
notamment pour faire après des contrôles
d'identité si besoin à tour jusqu'à
maintenant la sécurisation des
transports en commun était gérée par des
unités différentes selon les besoins
aujourd'hui 11 policiers sont affiliés
spécifiquement à cette mission on est
dans le cadre de la police de proximité
remettre du lien entre la police et les
usagers et euh à côté de ça on fera
également des missions de surveillance
sur des des faits qui nous seront
communiqués euh voilà des actes de
délinquance pour cibler certaines zones
en 2022 le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin avait promis la création
de ces unités dédiées au transport à
tour c'est désormais chose
fait